[Music]
I'm filling in for the GM again who is
ops I claim in that tournament slash
Flamel and this is games you should know
by heart where we pick sort of famous
classic games so if during the series
you say yeah RG knows this game well
that's kind of the point it's game is
that all Club players should know at
some point I did try to pick one that
maybe some people are not so familiar
with and this first game that we're
going to look at we might show two I
might show you
it's a rubenstein game so Rubenstein's
immortal I might show you my favorite
one that's my favorite rubenstein game
if we have time but this is George rot
Louie vs. Akiba Rubenstein and it was
played in Lodz 1907 okay so we're
looking at it from Rubenstein's point of
view he had the black pieces here and as
was the fashion at the time they played
the tirage and you know III tirage is
not supposed to be so overwhelming for
white but okay this is all quite normal
for the time the opening moves will kind
of get through negative 6 and here white
ends up taking on c5 and what's going to
end up happening in this game is white
is actually going to waste one or two
Tempe and black is going to find a way
to exploit that so we all kind of know
at the beginning of the game you know
you kind of want to get all your stuff
out and one go you don't want to
accelerate your opponent's development
so in this position he kind of helped
him out by letting black develop his
bishop if he had instead waited till
black move to fish up and then took on
c5 it would cost like a turn which is
why the main moves are either taking on
d5 or playing a3 so the main loops here
but we're going to see kind of a
illustrative example of how to take
advantage of the fact that you're up in
development so that's what the first
wasted tempo now a 386 b4 Bishop d6
okay so not hugely controversial so far
but here if you're in the last class I
told you in general
d2 is not a good square for the queen
and here again it's going to be a
mistake because white in this game is
going to end up playing Bishop d3
in Queen e2 so a more normal square for
the queen is e2 e2 or c2 or somewhere on
this diagonal somewhere over here those
are sort of the normal places for a
queen to go in the course of a chess
game and here again while you're going
to waste one more tempo so you wait to
the move letting the bishop into the
game and I was going to waste one more
tempo and that's going to be enough as
we're going to see and this can happen a
lot in a lot of games when you're ahead
tempo or to Tempe did it you know you
have to do something right away but it's
not always so easy to figure it out now
only after the bishop has moved do we
take on c4 please b5 and it's almost a
symmetrical position here except for
this Queen isn't here and the bishop
isn't here but after the Queen e2 now
after hearing capsules it's you know a
symmetrical position but I got this rook
move in kind of for free so black kind
of has to be better here because you
know it's like the same position but
it's my turn and I have my rook on d8 so
we could consider a normal move a move
like this was a great move but he
decides here and he must have calculated
already it's time for me to take some
action so you have to be careful when
you take action and chest it's like okay
whenever you do something you might be
making a mistake so you have to
calculate it very well if you don't have
any immediate action you can't do
something forceful then you would just
bring your other piece into the game but
here he plays the move like to e5
so you have to take my night pretty much
because otherwise I'm taking something
I'm so takes takes and the reason this
works is because black in this position
has a threat for example if I do nothing
what is black threat in this position
this is sort of key to understanding
this position yes
this will take spawn check yeah exactly
the point is Queen to d6 check and
you're on the bishops you went upon so
did I mess up everything by clicking
there so the size of the board just
changed slightly okay okay so in this in
this way that forces White's hand in
this position you have to deal with that
potential threat so he played f4 and the
bishop goes back and again it may look
like okay maybe f4 is good for me maybe
I can drive my pawn up here that's
certainly what white thought but after E
for black spends another turn developing
a piece and white again pushes his pawn
so black and spend a lot more time
developing its pieces than white and
here is where all the fun starts so
we're going to pause here forever
because this is the interesting position
and here black is actually winning
though to figure it out you have to play
like an immortal that's the only way so
at home you do want to pause see if you
can start to figure out some of the
moves I think maybe we can get some of
the ideas but I will give you guys some
time so we'll pause and we'll see what
you guys come up with here
okay so this is right an interesting
move that may come to mind and perhaps
this works clean takes is the obvious
follow-up so this is the I move that
we're going to sort of see in the game
ninety g4 yeah so this is is on the
right track for the game so you have
this idea of winning your exchange back
but also Queen to h4 this is definitely
on the right track and you know maybe
this works left a friend computer likes
it so this probably works as well but
the game might even be even more
accurate so we got all these ideas right
we want to play here and here we want to
throw this check in we want to like take
stuff we got all these ideas and that's
what's going to happen the tactics are
going to favor us because we've got all
of our stuff out before white did and
we're going to get these nice bishops
going on these diagonals we're going to
have the knight every single piece has a
potential function the queen is going to
go here so that's why things are going
to work out for black in the game he
decided to play check and now instead of
thinking the bishop he just plays
immediately rip to g4 if you take here
the point is I take your Bishop and now
I'm threatening to win material here and
also Ruby - looks pretty strong okay so
he played a move that seems very
sensible you just move the bishop you
know I want to trade the pieces so I'm
quite happy if you decide we'll try to
fish up I'm not going to get mated if
you train a lot of stuff and then what
is black play here it's actually so
finding the moves we're going to start
to become more and more difficult we got
sort of the right idea from the
beginning
and now he put a very nice move he
spoiled it by picking the actual best
move people don't want to know the
actual decimals they want to pretend
like this guy played a great immortal
game so how dare you come all the way
from Germany to tell us what the actual
best move is yeah so yeah thanks for
coming
ok so the point is mate and there's not
a whole lot you can really do about it I
don't know who wants to defend this but
it's not fun because I'll figure on the
rook that's the actual best move it's
not the most aesthetically pleasing
you know girlis time big chess artist
you love painting a chess candidates etc
and you know a lot of that your film in
like fashion and art or something today
the swindle wasn't even a fashion show
he played a more artistic move that's
also super strong and we'll just pretend
like he never said that Knight takes h2
nobody needs to know about that so what
is like actually play the best move of
all time for this game yeah
setting up for a beautiful finish well
the move in the game is off its barely
knowing that h2 is like slightly
stronger
was it not 9h - right yeah I'm not mad
eh - don't even think about that and
that doesn't exist no one needs to know
and the wreck of the night is attacked
that's in the mortal game so clean-ish
Fleur all right clean aged four was
played in the game okay so I have to
deal with this this threat of checkmate
that's obviously the most important
thing but you'll notice too I did unde
offend this bishop
so why played a quite natural move g3
well I protected I am attacking your
queen and I'm threatening your Bishop so
I'm hoping you realize okay you got to
just trade stuff you got to move your
queen away somewhere and okay maybe this
isn't so bad for me at all but
Rubinstein had some other ideas in mind
and so here is the beginning of a really
really fantastic position so this is
sort of the main start of a puzzle if
you're reading within a tactics book I
will give you guys lots of time there's
quite a lot to figure out here there are
there's this going on what's going on
what are these guys doing and he's going
to use all of his pieces on this attack
so we'll give you guys a couple minutes
here and you want to pause at home
because I think the more you figure this
out the prettier you'll realize it
actually is so I'll give you guys that
I'm in here to think about it
all right so mr. Germany coming up with
all the right moves here rook takes c3
leaving the Queen entry so one point is
you'll notice if I had taken here check
which seems like a logical move because
you know my bishop was attacked and I'm
taking a check and then I'll move my
clean away the problem is I can take
back with my knight I don't have to take
with my queen so the real problem is
this knife that's kind of holding the
position together for white so he took
on c3 totally ignoring this so black
better be winning or he just gave away
all this stuff and we'll see will he be
able to actually make use of all of the
stuff that's left on the board here I'll
take your queen okay all right I took
your clean I'm the best rook to d7
protecting your stuff looks to d2 all
right audience is on fire you guys seen
this you guys cheating over there with
your phones what's going on you got a
book in front of you to send that book
yeah look at that
rookie - you're trying to remove the
Queen from the defense of the bishop
well I mean how do you not take it okay
take it check
in 2g - maybe we're going to trade lots
of stuff you know maybe we're just going
to go you're gonna take my cleans I'm
going to take back rook see to check in
g3 you take my bishop I take your knight
we're going to trade a lot of stuff all
right I'll just whatever the outcome
with that endgame is I'll play that as
white I have no choice
yeah
rook to c2 wins but his move was
prettier and better yeah so embarrassing
yeah um what is the main continuation
here there's something funny I can do I
think I can throw like this move in or
something there's something funny I can
do and let's not think so that's too
hard so Lane six
how embarrassing you had like meeting
three or four rook F - then I wants to
take this with either thing okay oh
that's taking way too long long time for
that yeah nobody has time so he played
an even faster wind and much prettier
one so like this attend the squares
attacked
I like that Square for some reason
[Music]
I know some reason that'll be a big hand
9 th - just ignoring that everything is
doing everything to you know H 3 the
final move of the game so yeah the point
is you're not stopping me from doing
that your queen is pinned so even if you
take this it's still made so this is
okay obviously a fantastic idea let's
just go back just to the part where we
sacrificed here this position after
Queen age for everything was looking
great I'm attacking your bishop I'm
attacking your queen but just due to the
strength of the bishop pair here
he's breaking bishops we're able to
consider sacking the Queen deflecting
the Queen taking and exploiting the pin
so okay too many this is Rubenstein's
best game it's obviously a fantastic
tactical finished any game hopefully you
guys enjoyed it and since we got through
that pretty quick the audience was kind
of on fire we got a good audience
tonight I will show you another game
that's not very popular by Rubenstein
but in my mind this is actually one of
his best games it's a lot more
positional so we taught the song as a
you know awesome tactician that game is
obviously amazing if you get to play
moves like that but here we're going to
see a much different Rubinstein a very
positional approach and in this game I
like it because white just really
squeezes the most out of a position he's
going to have as well it's gonna have a
backwards pawn and he's going to show us
how to take advantage of that fact
positionally this was played between
Rubinstein and George soul with from
Lodz 1908 so the next year and
unsurprisingly it was at Rush and
unsurprisingly he played the Rubinstein
variation and okay this oak this method
playing g3 was actually considered to be
so good that even tirage himself said
this is the refutation of the trois you
can't play it anymore then probably
isn't true and good people still play
this today but the main point is we put
a bishop here and we attack d5 our
Knight attacks it if we take this pawn
we have a queen that can detect this we
have a bishop that can go take this
Knight and remove a defender of d5 it's
all about putting pressure on d5 and
eventually black will be forced to make
a concession either playing c4 which is
the most common way or to take here and
then leave yourself with an isolated
pawn so also this was quite new because
he had just invented this so black
decides here to take which is not a very
popular move today because of the game
Queen to b6 now it's quite interesting
what white did I think a lot of people
when they see an isolated pawn well you
want to keep that pawn there you don't
want to help black build his center you
know you don't want to take care but
will notice something quite interesting
about this position
why is he able to do this and you know
why would you get rid of his that
weakness there well just castles Bishop
e7 and let's try to think here white now
needs to come up with a plan so let's
kind of look at blacks pawn structure
see if we can identify a weakness and
then we'll see if we can find a way to
exploit that weakness that's sort of a
planning exercise that we need to do in
this class so what is the weak Square
and then how should we take advantage of
it yeah c6 is definitely a weak square
we do want to end up attacking this on
and also what I quite like about this
game is it's a good illustration of how
to deal with a backwards pawn and very
often it's a three-step plan the first
step is to control the square in front
of the pond the second step is to
blockade the pond
same way and then the third step is to
bear a whole bunch of pressure down on
the pond so we're going to see that
three-step process it's just a perfect
example of it so step one control the
square in front of the pond so c5 is
going to be the most important square
for now let's control c5 then we can
block a tit and then we can eventually
put a lot of pressure on the C pawn and
let me give you a whole bunch of moves
what are all the different ways we can
control c5 we want to think about all
our pieces yeah this should be three we
do have to be careful because if you
know B pond is attacked but for now
we're not really calculating Bishop to
e3 definitely controls the square you
know if you do play it right away you
have to calculate what happens if you
ticks here but you also set Knight to a4
so that's two pieces that can control c5
what else
it's not too early for the Queen no and
we're so we're not actually calculating
so where could the Queen possibly go
where she would control see five is more
than one answer but see tail would be
one of them and depending on where
blacks pieces are okay maybe d4 look no
so we're not we're just trying to see
where they could possibly go because we
realized after 94 maybe this Queen is
going to move and okay this guy's the
only guy that really can't go there cuz
it's dark square but all the other
pieces can so these rooks some
combination of doubling on the C file
and that's not so obvious how black will
completely control it obviously he has
these guys potentially the Knights could
go somewhere where we control c5 but
it's actually wiped it should be able to
get control of that square so now we'll
begin to calculate let's try to get the
move in the right order here what do we
think the first move the white plague
was nine a four and you'll notice the
white castle before doing this so
there's no little checks or anything
funny going on so now your queen has to
move the Queen went to b5 okay I'm still
fighting for control of this square
continued Queen to c2 is is an okay move
the one thing that you might want to
worry about though too is in this game
he actually probably didn't want to
block his rooks in he kind of wants his
weakest pieces to go there first so by
starting with your strongest piece you
might limit your options going forward
but it's probably an okay move yeah
this should be three was played so yeah
is determining where the weakest stuff
should go first
and now works the one that's coming
castles whoops c1 and now we have three
people here so white totally controls
the square Bishop to four and this is
also funny so he's like I'll play Bishop
here I'm on your iPod
I'm tempting you to play the move f3 but
as we'll see Rubinstein actually uses
the flute to his advantage and we'll try
to understand how so it looks like a
great accomplishment for black i
provoked f3 i blunted your bishop now
what's your bishop going to do so we
still have this idea and there's a lot
of stuff going on now we understand sort
of the role of these guys and probably
the Queen - so what's going on on the
Queen side is I'm controlling c5 and I'm
going to blockade it so as we saw in the
last game he's sort of a master of using
all his pieces and another planning
exercise if you guys are in this
position what would you do with those
pieces he has a very crafty maneuver
right this will give you sorry your
knight access to g4 it kind of weakens
efore in the future so this is you know
obviously one plan and now okay I could
push my F pawn and then maybe I can get
my broken to the bishop into the game
but yeah he is sort of a master of
controlling all these squares you know
he's like that's all that's all me you
know you don't get that you don't get to
do anything funny around my king yeah
yeah that's yeah it's unlikely we're
doing anything at this diagonal unless
there's some sacrifices or something but
doesn't look promising this looks very
unlikely because you have a bishop on
that diagonal if your bishop moved by
Omaha the officials can get off
so this is also an unlikely diagonal the
Bishop F wonder springs to mind and then
I can come out this way I'll have to
move my rope and my pond but maybe I can
find a more active Square over there and
we're going to see what he decides to do
with this rook so we'll leave it to that
for the moment that's our square so now
we've blockaded we controlled it we're
blocking it and now we're going to
slowly put as much pressure on c6 as
possible okay you attacked my bishop I
defended it and at some point I am
hoping to trade the bishop you'll notice
he went with his Bishop first and not as
Knight not just because it was deep on
would be hanging but I want to trade
these guys if I'm white because I'm
trying to fight for a dark square so
trading a dark square Bishop makes a lot
of sense for me look up to that's the
idea now after Bishop f1 on somewhere
Brooksie to that's his idea that's how
he's going to use all of his pieces okay
so black fights for control of the
square I don't mind trading but now we
look at c5 again and we realize well
maybe black has got some control at that
square so he did remove our block Haider
so we got to fight for it again what is
the most accurate move for white there's
a couple different ways what's the best
move here for white yeah bishop f1 is is
that very good yeah if there's nothing
wrong with this moving he's going to
play that in a second it doesn't control
c5 I guess that as a media focus was
more on controlling c5 rather than
improving his King side Queen d4 yeah
and that's good a lot of people in this
position they're tempted to play a move
like Queen c2 which is also okay
one of the big differences is well first
of all I want that square for this rook
that's where you at home could use all
my pieces and I'm also kind of in the
way of this guy and I want my weaker
stuff and I want to be in the way of all
my weaker stuff and also from d4 if
black ever has the idea of my d5 well
I've stopped that for the moment so
Queens a d4 alright rippln back alright
I control the square so now I have time
to improve my pieces all right so black
is is getting ready to defend passively
III attacking the Queen Queen goes back
and we block it again takes we take with
our rook so we can get maximum pressure
on the thief on getting ready to defend
and light just double so white has
clearly secured a big positional
advantage we did everything we wanted
now we're attacking the pawn
everything's looking great but it's not
always so easy okay you achieve this
position that's great
I mean you're you're playing for the win
here but you need to increase the
pressure so I played a really strong
move here I wonder if the audience could
see it Bishop b5 the trickiest let's see
let's give black a move does that change
your mind it's the trickiest I do give
you that so even in this position that
is the trickiest so I could defend it
again somehow or lose some material you
played the trickiest move it's not good
night for thinking because I've been
here since 9:00 I should just defend my
stuff
now also good for white yeah we should
play v3 mm-hmm yes um we don't have to
we don't have to be tied down with this
well yeah you want one step farther and
the idea again is to put pressure on the
square so you went there with the bishop
because you're a tricky guy he wanted to
go there with a pawn it's the same idea
except for them really taking this even
if you defend it again so he kind of d5
is a big threat so black played a six
and now actually we have two weaknesses
usually one's not enough so now we got
two just in case and he immediately goes
after this guy and okay you're just
really strangled here as black because
now everybody you stuck defending
everything and why does everything
covered rook b8 he's saying why don't we
trade you take here I take here I get
rid of a weakness
oh it just plays a three in black has
some serious problems it's it's not so
easy for him to defend his stuff and
really he's losing a pawn here because
after this move we see what usually
happens in these types of positions
well one player is just crushing you
positionally well the tactics are going
to flow for the guy with the better
pieces and so here there is a little
tactic not nearly as something as the
first game but it is a tactic and we'll
pause here see if writer audience just
got a lot higher rated so we'll see if
our audience can come up with move that
white played in this position
now get your stock search out and see if
you can find it yeah
Queen e5 what's the idea
and putting pressure on the enemy castle
well yeah I don't want to trade Queens
that's for sure you know I don't maybe
still still a lot better but we had no
intrigues but there's something a lot
more concrete there's a tactic here
Castle take c6
yeah earth takes c6 this is the tactic
and okay so here's the point and we take
here okay so we've won upon again a big
accomplishment but you know sometimes
winning these positions are still very
tricky so he defends a spawn and we deny
you anything on the C file and so what
do you want to take in which it takes a
sec yes this is okay we try to remember
yes I think this is should be okay if
I'm on this guy so I think I can take
care
and then what's something like this that
also would be okay but I do have some
counterplay am I missing something
sure okay rook takes a picture I'm sure
you can and again I just you know
grabbed upon this guy still is weak so I
you know can potentially use this guy
and all these guys to gang up on this
guy and this guy
yeah because this is week and this is
going to be week and I still have
control of the C files you have no
counterplay this shouldn't work out well
for you
so it is actually it's quite bad already
there's not a whole lot of good moves
okay so he keeps the Queen's on the
board so it's just upon yeah but he's
not playing in the ninth
so the pawn meant something and I like
this too so his next couple moves
he just defends against anything that
could ever happen on the second rank if
black ever gets active you'll never do
anything over there okay I'm going to
swing my rook to the C file which is
what happened and you get nothing to do
over there
and these are sort of annoying moves if
you're defending here okay the guys just
improving his King he's just fixing the
pawn structure on that side he's not
really doing anything and meanwhile I
have to sit here and defend and cry you
know so yeah he played here which is
desperately trying to get some counter
play but it's not going to work because
as the audience has mentioned he comes
in and now he has a very simple plan
push yeah push push and black resigned
so really a positional masterpiece let's
just go back one more time just really
quick here so in this position not
afraid to change the pawn structure so
there still is a backwards pawn and then
it was all about targeting c5 so we've
got all of his pieces to attack if f3
actually helped us because we had a
clever little maneuver so we weren't
afraid to exchange we kept control of
the square you've got all of our pieces
into the
tack and then from there the tactics
eventually savored white and then upon
up with no counterplay he was able to
learn the game there's absolutely no
counter play ever and okay eventually
black just collapse so that's one of my
favorite Rubenstein games so you got to
see two of them here I hope that was
very instructive you saw tactics game
you saw strategy game and if you like
that go ahead hit like share subscribe
and we'll see you guys next week
[Music]